first of all really quickly i have a
picture to show you um i did the cover
of instyle
i shot it myself during the pandemic and
um
i posed for a picture inside so those
are good american jeans and i just
wanted to tell you
i think it's the best jeans company in
the world i love it so much
oh my gosh that's so nice of you thank
you you look awesome and you shot it oh
my god
thank you and i after having two
children
well i don't look the same in jeans it's
a
different era in my life 46 and two kids
i'm not
in my 20s you know it's i don't have
that body anymore
and putting on your jeans i feel good
about myself and i want to thank you
because you've like
oh my gosh really that's so so nice of
you and you know
uh that was one of the reasons why me
and my business partner emma we decided
to make
good american is because i my weight has
always fluctuated my whole life
and we wanted to be all inclusive and
going up
to a size um 24 at the time was
really important to us and whoever
wanted to carry our brand they had to
carry
the same the full size range and never
separate the size range i never wanted
someone to feel
you know isolated again and like oh you
have to be ushered up to a different
floor
so that was one of the main reasons why
we started good american
i'm a giant fluctuator too and then
i had two kids and then i was like oh
god
now this is the body i have to shop for
clothes with
oh my gosh you are and then i was like
all right you need to start
exercising and i i think i needed that
outlet and i've been so inspired by you
who talk about
working out as something that's like
such a good mental
outlet as well as physical it's so weird
because in my
i'm a little different in my 20s i think
i was chubbier and then i
got a divorce i think at 29 and
um i really needed an outlet and i
needed i just turned to the gym and it
started really slow and now it's
really religious for me i do it super
early in the morning before my daughter
wakes up it's a way to start my day i
feel
so good i feel mentally clear and
i will tell you when i'm upset when i'm
sad when i'm angry
i those workouts are so beast i am like
i'm an animal in there so i know how
therapeutic the gym can be for me and if
i
didn't have that i would probably be a
monster throughout my day and
it's really my form of therapy and i
just feel so accomplished and badass
after the gym
i don't know if this is assuming because
i hate assumption
and i'm not an assuming person but from
a
person watching your journey from afar
who doesn't know you
you always seem to like take your whole
thing with like
physical wellness as like a really
independent
for no one else but yourself it was sexy
and empowered
and it always had the right messaging to
me
thank you i mean and you know this way
more than i do especially in the
world that this is it's so people crit
criticize you and tell you you're fat
even if you're not and you start to
believe you're fat like there's so many
things that
instead of people tell giving you
compliments or just saying nothing at
all
it's really so easy to fall victim to
okay i'm just going to go on a crash
diet because i have to lose 20 pounds
because
some magazine called me fat or something
i and
because of my family and i've i never
felt
any of the things that people would say
about me i don't know why
i guess i had this i think just like a
force field of protection around me
through positive
words and love through my family and i
always attest that like i went on my
physical wellness journey when it was my
time to do so you have to be willing and
ready and you have to be
able and just you have to want to you
have to because it's a lifestyle i don't
i don't really believe in diets i i
believe in eating healthy and i believe
in making lifestyle changes and
it took a lot of inner strength for me
to do things on my
terms when i was ready and in my way
because i felt like that was the
healthiest way
yeah no it is and at some at one point
you were like i was 29 i was getting
divorced
you know i had a coping mechanism and i
was gonna be like it's food right that
was mine you were like and i went to the
gym i was like oh
no i wish that was my coping mechanism i
need it to be my coping mechanism i'm
better about it now
definitely i found my balance
yeah and you know what food used to be
my coping mechanism you know when my dad
died so many things but i
had to go through that and learn okay
yes
the food mechanism felt so good
for the moment but then afterwards i
would feel so bad about
myself but i you have to experience it
and i had to go through that and like i
said be willing and
able like okay so i tried the food
coping situation for a couple years
and that didn't make me feel good in
fact it made me probably a little
more depressed and made me feel bad
about myself and
and then you know so i it took me years
to figure out what made me actually get
through a really challenging time in my
life
in a healthy way do you think that
is what growing up is cause lately i've
been like
for the first time in my life like
growing up isn't overrated it's kind of
awesome
it is it's awesome and you know i used
to be
of course i don't think any of us love
to get older
but sometimes i look back at my 20s and
i'm like oh i
love that i had my daughter in my 30s i
wanted to have kids so
badly in my 20s and it didn't happen and
there's a reason for everything and i'm
you know but you get to then i'm like
i'm so happy i got to live and
experience my 20s and
you're just it's so cliche like i'm
older and wiser and i'm more confident
and you kind of just
are more comfortable with who you are
and maybe more comfortable
saying no than i probably was in my 20s
so i
i do think getting older is a really
beautiful
thing and you can make it a really
negative thing i'm all for
how you perspective on everything and
i'm going to choose to make this a
really beautiful thing
getting older well i love hearing your
perspectives and
you've partnered with docenco to tackle
some of those issues that result from
pregnancy we're talking about the body
now this is about hair and i
loved so much um that you are doing
non-plastic
thank you so much because if someone
like you does it it's gonna start a huge
chain reaction
and this is what we need to raise our
kids on a safe planet please tell me
about it and thank you
for making that choice uh because you're
gonna change the game for people
um so the no plastic thing is a huge i
no single-use plastic is something i
really try to do as much as possible
and docenco i actually found i was
um just finished breastfeeding i started
losing my hair especially in
like this area after breastfeeding
i tried a couple collagen companies or
brands and
you know nothing was really working i
was kind of like is this
i don't i don't know it just wasn't
working for me i kind of thought it was
focus and someone
suggested dosim co at the time they were
only in new zealand and someone sent me
something and
i tried it and in 30 days i kid you not
i noticed a significant difference in my
hair skin and nails so i
being the dork that i am i reached i
wrote them an email and i was like hey i
love your products would you guys start
selling to the us i'm such a dork
and they were just blown away that i
even
knew about their company and then they
flew out here to the united states we
had meetings and i
um we just really hit it off i loved
what the company stood for
and everything is there's no fillers and
no artificial anything it's
as pure as you can get um we have eight
different product lines in it we have
pure collagen
and it's just good for your hair your
skin your nails
acne eczema psoriasis it's just good for
your joints there's really no
downside to collagen i love that you're
doing this i love
that you have a good perspective and
thank you so much um it's a real
pleasure
to talk with you so nice talking to you
too and thank you so much for having me
on
and just for sharing your stories with
me
thank you say hello to the whole family
and um obviously keeping up with the
kardashians airs thursday at 8 7 central
on
e in its swan song season
i am convinced you guys have a plan b
like you're the kardashians
what's coming up next we always have a
plan b
i knew it
you